escenas de desesperación y pánico en
este pequeño hospital de bis nor a 150
kilómetros de nueva delhi
los familiares intentan resucitar en
vano a una mujer que se quedó sin
oxígeno el doctor de turno en urgencias
no da abasto ante la afluencia de
pacientes y se ve obligado a dejar
algunos enfermos en manos de sus
acompañantes
ningún doctor acude a visitarnos nadie
nos dice que medicina dar a los
pacientes
tenemos que ir a por el oxígeno nosotros
mismos el martes cuatro personas
murieron en la sala de urgencias en una
hora escasea el material y las
condiciones básicas de higiene hay tanto
desorden pueden ver las condiciones de
la habitación como pueden a recuperarse
aquí
mientras que la incidencia parece
empezar a bajar en las grandes ciudades
preocupa el incesante colapso del
sistema sanitario en las zonas rurales
donde vive más del 60% de la población
no dejan de llegar pacientes de zona
tanto rurales como urbanas hemos
involucrado a dos hospitales privados
pero el número es muy amplio
no hay duda la cifra de personas
contagiadas es muy altas mientras que en
algunas zonas se empieza a faltar madera
para las tradicionales incineraciones
hindúes algunos cadáveres son arrojados
al ganges este miércoles india registró
el récord de 4 mil 205 muertes por kobe
19 en 20
horas